do you think trump will win or lose i
probably lose at the moment
it's he's got it's tough and it goes
moment to moment doesn't it it's moment
to moment it really is debates could
could could make him the favorite again
because bidens is not a good debater and
he's kind of mentally not there but i
think trump's fighting a lot of battles
that are losing battles yeah like the
economy is collapsing
this coronavirus was not really handled
well um
he pours like forget politics so i keep
explaining my friends you're like super
pro trump
i'm like if there was a ceo of a company
and half the people in it thought he was
trying to kill them
even if they were wrong you can't get
rid of half of them
right you got to get rid of him like he
pours gasoline
and like every day whether he's he might
not be trying to kill them but every day
gets in the elevator and he's like
maybe i'll kill you like like
wait he's doing it again he's doing it
and then the other people the company
like
that's the way he is yeah he's joking
that's what he does
yeah it's a joke and they're like no he
said there was poise in the pen he's
gonna stab me they go
will you stop it's amazing how we can't
live in this schizophrenia forever
so many people take everything he says
so so seriously yeah
it's like um and also i think a lot of
people want him to be something that he
isn't a lot of time yeah it's like
a lot of people elected him knowing he
was a cr like
crazy wild odd businessman yeah he's a
con
artist yeah he's the most successful con
artist of all time
which is why there's part of me that
likes him i know he's full of [ __ ] the
people on the right think he was chosen
by jesus
to free every child that's being
trafficked or whatever
the people on the left think he's adolf
hitler the reality is
he's a riverboat casino hustler he's a
huckster
and he's just been able to bluff because
he knows social media
and he knows and i think that's the real
story
that's what makes him more interesting
to me yeah he's the most successful
[ __ ] card shark three card monty
dealer
[ __ ] slum lord that you've ever
known like he's doing it on the world
stage he doesn't have a clue what he's
gonna say
right he just lets it fly yeah he lets
it rip and that character to me
not that he's this omnipotent force of
evil
or that he's uh this amazing angel
the idea that he's just kind of a
regular guy
who's a con makes him more impressive to
me
and it makes the story actually a lot
more interesting oh this
vote if you want a good show if you
don't have cable anymore but you still
want to be a part like if you're able to
have these separatists and not
get it like sometimes i get my boots in
the mud yeah
if you're able to keep your boots out of
the mud there's no greater
show than the show we're watching than
the show we're watching yeah
it's obvious you're gonna be fun i mean
america is gonna give you money
you know like um but i i also
think well i don't know if that's good
but right now they are
right now people are getting mailed
money and can't handle it
yeah some people are getting guardian
mailed money home
yeah once a month and they're just and
they just
cannot hack it you can't do it
um they got to go to applebee's and just
lick the floor well there's a thing
i remember when he won which i thought
he was going to win
to me it became really obvious yeah but
when he won i was like holy [ __ ] the
next day and i
i think everybody had this moment
they're like
i could be president yeah well i think
everybody had that moment and then
everybody had
this this very interesting moment too
and it happens
in every thriller in every thriller of
most thrillers there's a scene where the
car is dangling
off the off the mountain right
and everybody's you're kind of in that
moment of being like
what's gonna happen now yeah when's it
gonna fall it's gotta fall right
or does it get pulled back does it get
you know how does it work just did the
mercedes-benz back up in jurassic park
and
you know somehow and the problem is
we've been living in that moment
for four years like that moment of like
tension and anxiety and what happens and
some people are like oh this is fun it's
a movie
and then some people are like no but
they could die and some people like yeah
but they're not real and
some people like no but they are
actually real some of them are real and
they're like good points some of them
are real
so it's just i look at it so differently
everybody's so invested in one side of
the other side
i look at the guy and i'm like nobody's
had a wilder life than this guy
yeah nobody like he might have has one
of the most crazy lives in history
i can't believe that more black men yeah
don't low-key
think that donald trump is oh they do
because he's like
some people complete like he's a
the g he's like yeah in that regard yeah
of like
money cash hoes men in general i think
because we tend to like
just we're not like i think women might
think about things a little more
right but men might just take something
at face value
and sometimes the stuff he says you just
go [ __ ] hilarious
yeah and you just move on about your day
whereas a woman will be like uh that was
horrible
like he said a horrible thing and he's
our president you're like yeah but he's
it's just funny but also when you grow
up poor especially i mean growing up
poor and white like you never have
any i never thought any politicians were
really much but cl like it always seemed
like
like they never came to our neighborhood
and did anything you know
i remember the richest guy i knew would
drive by our neighborhood he was a
veterinarian and he would throw
dead animals into the ditch outside of
our apartment complex
and i remember we would throw like
carcass at like
like cossackses and like you know goat
occipitals and [ __ ] at each other just
you know
and just rattle off you know if you got
a rib cage you would just have unlimited
bullets
from true detectives this entire child
but just like
and that was like kind of like he was a
city councilman or something i think and
that was the closest
we ever got to play there was a senator
who lived in my town
clearly a mob guy all right his name was
like al d'amato he's like a respected
guy people know he is but he clearly is
like a local
goon and he was just like he would just
walk around the san gennaro festival
just like eating this little custard and
like just
drinking booze i'm like this dude
doesn't give a [ __ ] drink in the blood
yeah of his grandparents he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about any of this now he's a nice
guy and my family liked him but it's
like they don't care
he had a poker alliance let's look at
him right here there he is alfonse dude
alfonse d'amato yeah he would just walk
around and like you know he'd have like
a little eggplant parmesan he'd be
twirling linguine yeah
and a little uh like a little paper a
little a plastic cop yeah maybe twirl a
linguini and just walk around eating it
like
you know they'd be playing like when the
moon hits
and i'm like what are the chances this
guy's uh i bet he's pretty swayable yeah
yeah i bet you could put them in a room
hand them a little money and
d'amato is chairman of the poker players
alliance
a non-profit organization set up to help
protect and fight for the rights of
poker players in the united states
that's long island that's where it came
from
we protected the pokemon and look at his
dimey
dimes yeah sound like brennan's child
right now but his dimey
dime of a wife yeah look how
he won her in a game yeah
here's the interesting thing i think
about trump i think he's he's a
reflection of what we have become
a country that does shady business right
that we're all on our third wife
we have a semi-autistic child everybody
has a semi-autistic child
and i don't mean this in any negative
way i just to me he's like
he's the mirror we don't want to see
like yeah
in a lot of ways you know what bothers
him
about really rich people is like what
they will say to country club to each
other privately he'll just go out and
say to united nations
and they're like whoa whoa you guys are
trash
you're like you know he's he's the dad
in your neighborhood who's like this
neighborhood's changing and you're like
shut up dad imagine he now he's the
president
now that guy's a prince now the guy who
sits on his patio
smoking a cigar saying failed racist
things is now the president of the
united states
it's a problem but it's also the most
predictable thing ever yeah
because we love celebrity we're obsessed
we love the idea of somebody that we
know
he got in the game we know him he has
name recognition we followed him forever
he was a reality tv he was off script
also he came in at a time like
yeah he came in at a time where things
were getting all like everyone was so
tired of this boring they were boring
and they were good
things were kind of good like even
though things weren't good for
millions of people all we really look at
is like media and everything and obama
was in and everybody's like yeah things
are kind of good
and then we were like wait a minute what
if we just throw this wrecking ball
at like it might just be interesting
again and then we didn't know now we're
just living in the time when we're like
oh we didn't know how interesting it was
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah